what is going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and i
know a lot of people were really excited
about morbius and the possibility of
andrew garfield spider-man returning in
some way shape or form and possibly
being in the movie morbius and if not in
morbius hopefully returning to the sony
spider-man universe whether in his own
film or an upcoming spider-man film like
craven the hunter or madame webb but now
i'm actually quite concerned for andrew
garfield spider-man because of what is
happening right now with morbius now
some of the press has had the
opportunity to see morbius in full and
they have posted their initial reactions
online and unfortunately they're not
very good now i'll go over these and
talk about what to actually expect from
the movie morbius but we also need to
talk about what this means for andrew
garfield's future in the sony spider-man
universe it looks like it could be
really really bad but there are ways to
save it so let's go ahead and talk about
what exactly is going on here and if you
love marvel and you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so we're going to be talking
about morbius a little bit right now
like i said the initial reactions are
out and the post credit scenes have
actually been leaked now i'm not really
going to go over them in detail because
i don't want to go over that many
spoilers for the movie but i will
generally talk about them just so we can
link it to spider-man now here's kind of
the first red flag that i heard about
morbius that made me go oh no spider-man
might be in trouble and sony and marvel
studios also made it very clear that tom
holland spider-man is not going to be
the spider-man that could have possibly
appeared in morbius and other
sony-pictured universe films which leads
us to believe along with all the reports
and the rumors that andrew garfield
spider-man would be the one in the sony
pictures universe in the trailer for
morbius we see morbius walking down an
alleyway and on the side of the wall is
a picture of spider-man that got
everybody super freaked out super hyped
up very excited however
it doesn't look like that's in the movie
according to some of the press that has
seen the film already they took that
part out you no longer see spider-man on
the wall now the big question is why did
they do this now i think this is kind of
a good thing but also kind of a bad
thing according to some people that i've
spoken to that originally was indeed
going to be in the film it's not
something they just put in the trailer
to hype people up that was actually
supposed to be there however as many
people may know they did a lot of
reshoots for morbius recently and
changed a few things including michael
keaton coming back to do some reshoots
himself and one of the things they
changed of course with spider-man coming
off the wall now of course it's a bad
thing because well they kind of took
spider-man out of the movie i would not
expect spider-man to show up anywhere in
this movie even in the post-credits
scene in which he doesn't actually show
up but we'll kind of talk about that in
a bit because it is related to
spider-man but on the better note
hopefully they took that part out of the
movie because they have other plans for
him after the release of spider-man no
way home andrew garfield spider-man got
his redemption in the film everybody
loved andrew garfield spider-man and
spider-man no way home he gave an
amazing emotional performance and
everybody wants him back everybody wants
the amazing spider-man 3 to happen now
there's even a petition going on out
there about it and the official
spider-man twitter account has even said
that they have acknowledged everybody
wanting to do that and they've
acknowledged the make tasm 3 hashtag but
they also said they're not the studio
they don't make films but they're still
sony so sony has definitely acknowledged
this and hopefully with the massive
success that spider-man no way home had
and the big appreciation for angie
garfield spider-man hopefully this made
sony rethink some things and think about
how to incorporate andrew garfield
spider-man in their sony spider-man
universe somehow and hopefully that's
where these changes are coming from
because as i'll talk about in just a bit
there are plans for spider-man with sony
they make this very clear and morbius
but let's talk about what some of the
critics are saying so far because it
looks like they're pretty disappointed
now let me add that you should see this
movie and make an opinion for yourself
don't just listen to the opinions of
other people just because they don't
like something or like it doesn't mean
that that's how you have to feel make
your own opinion here's what sab astley
from collider had to say well morbius is
about as bad as you were expecting a
2005 plot collides with visually
confusing cgi to create a bit of a
snoozefest but don't worry they saved
the worst for last featuring some of the
worst post-credit scenes you've ever
seen sony are off their rocker this was
kind of one of my bigger fears for
morbius because they finished shooting
this thing over three years ago i
believe now of course it was delayed due
to the pandemic and that's no one's
fault but it's changed dates so many
times but wolf of geek street said in
morbius matt smith gloriously hams up
the place and oliver would deliver some
visual flair to the action sequences
aside from that the bad plotting and
messy cgi confusing editing and worst
sound mix result in absolute incoherence
but the post credits managed to outdo it
all so this review says that it's bad
but the post credits are worse now from
what i've heard about the post credits
again i won't go into details about them
but if you don't want to know anything
about them i'm briefly going to talk
about slide spoilers from what these
critics have said about the post credits
the two of them are connected to each
other don't make that much sense and
they kind of talk about spider-man they
don't show spider-man but they lead us
to believe that there is going to be
something with spider-man happening in
the future i mentioned this because most
of the critics are mentioning the post
credits as well cameron howe says
morbius is just as disjointed and boring
as you expected it to be clearly
butchered in an edit by a studio who had
no clue what they wanted to do with it
not that there's a good film trapped in
there mid credits are joke but stick
around if you like rolling your eyes and
there are a few other reviews out there
that talk about how confusing the story
is but we really don't need to dive into
any more reviews now i think it's very
clear that they didn't really know what
they wanted to do with morbius i think
originally they had planned on some type
of spider-man being in the film and i
hope that it changed because they want
to incorporate andrew garfield
spider-man into their universe but now
i'm kind of concerned spider-man knowing
home was awesome but it was because it
was partnered with marvel studios and
took place inside of the mcu kevin feige
was in charge if they make the amazing
spider-man 3 sony's going to be in
complete control of it marvel studios
isn't going to be involved at all unless
sony asks them to help in which they
might not they probably won't actually
now like i said the post credit seems to
at least tease that something is going
to happen with spider-man and i want to
assume that it's andrew garfield
spider-man considering everything that
we've heard but what does this mean does
this mean that the amazing spider-man 3
is coming does this mean that andrew
garfield is going to be in craven the
hunter or madame webb or a spider woman
movie that sony is developing because it
does seem very clear sony has of course
their own spider-man universe but there
is no spider-man it just doesn't make
sense but it does seem like they have a
plan to include spider-man in it in some
way shape or form but andrew garfield
spider-man had such a redemption in
spiderman no way home i'm now kind of
worried for him because at this point i
don't necessarily want him brought into
this mess now morbius could be an
amazing movie for some people and if it
is awesome and craven the hunter could
be an amazing movie as well madame webb
could be great and sony could turn it
around after this because again morbius
was shot over three years ago it went
through a bunch of reshoots a bunch of
delays a lot can happen in three years
and again spider-man no way home might
have changed what sony wanted to do with
spider-man so this could be a good thing
that morbius is kind of messy not for
morbius the movie itself but for the
future of spider-man and other
spider-man related films i'm hoping
things are getting messy because they're
making changes to incorporate a
spider-man in their universe i hope it's
andrew garfield spider-man and i hope
they do it right but again i'm kind of
concerned but let me know what you guys
think about this in the comments down
below and are you still excited to see
morbius after hearing some of these
critic reviews of course i'm still going
to go see it and i hope it's not as bad
as everybody's talking about but let me
know your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all of the
latest marvel news as always thank you
all so much for watching woof